then my mom's sitting in front of me she
goes like this tilts One Cheek up
and one starts [__]
[Music]
laughing welcome back to careful boys
today we're talking about if you could
erase one thing one event from your
memory oh what would you choose where do
you start man really yeah oh yeah
so many people
died in his memor forget they ever
lived you really have a lot you H to
like embarrassing moments yeah but you
don't think they made you who you are
now I think I could have done without
some of
those uh oh God here's an embarrassing
stupid one uh when like this is my my
first real serious girlfriend and um
this is like when I was I want to say 16
and then uh she she had this guy in her
school we went to different schools and
this other guy had asked her to prom
when she was um supposed to go with me
and I think like I got so pissed cuz I
was a f little hotthead back then I got
so mad uh the next time I went to visit
her I found out where he lived and I
found out it was just like down the
block from her house and I remember I I
put in a backpack this the biggest
machet that my dad owned I packed it in
the bag and then I was like all right
I'll be right back I'm going to go pay
him a visit and I started walking over
to his house God knows what the [__] I
was going to do what were you going to
do I don't know kill him I was crazy
just show it and then she she started
crying and it was just a big scene and I
think that's what I really wanted I just
wanted a scene you know cuz I'm a idiot
I thought he was going to like redo his
garden or something no but then but then
like I think like because of that then
like my my friends who from high school
who had never seen me act like that
because I was like see like just a goof
I think that changed how they saw me a
little bit and they were like oh he's
funny but he could snap at any moment
which was kind of like like what a
goofball yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah which
he's unhinged yeah right which I thought
was like but then I never acted that way
until I started dating because it
[__] made me nuts yeah for sure um
does smack know about this story nah she
doesn't know about that now she does but
it's like cuz I just remembered it right
now when I think of like [__] that just
was so un necessary you don't have to
share
everything yeah it's like that didn't
make me who I was that was more of like
a that was pretty stupid thing that like
who knows and and even that guy found
out that I was doing that and it made
him [__] weird oh yeah like it made
him really weird cuz I saw him another
time at a at a dance well he was like
dude this guy wants to [__] chop me
up he's wearing hockey pads everywhere I
saw him at a dance convention in the
Long Beach Convention Center like way
back in the day when when the schools
were like all the schools have to like
do like dances or some [__] uh and then
he was I was standing on the top of a
Stairway and he was at the bottom and I
I knew it was him and I I threw a bottle
at
him oh [__] oh I thought you had like a
a met you made a mess no this was like a
year later I didn't grow out of this
type of thinking for years C that's why
I was like why the [__] do I do these
dumb things and then um ran the bully
yeah and all he did was was ask her to
[__] problem like he had no idea he
should have [__] known he should he
violated your territory dude yeah but
that's so stupid now you got to let him
know who the king of the castle is
brother okay so after that my my high
school friends never let me live it down
that I have some [__] weird double
agenda like are you always going to kill
somebody today
like made of you about it it was like a
joke cuz they were like what the F Ryan
are you a killer yeah but it's so stupid
like all It Ever Was was just like I
just wanted to be like noticed by her in
that way of like I'll kill for you babe
yeah but that's so psycho it's so
[__] that's cuckoo [__] no it's just
teenage boy [__] yeah but like it's so
like it's so developmentally unnecessary
it's like you could take an easier route
to find out that that's not for you you
know yeah you could reach healthy
sooner yeah that's mine I would take
that away and everything residual from
that so if you could erase one thing or
event from your memory what would you
choose Nick I'm trying to think of a
good one I'm thinking of one in uh
this is like it whenever I think I'm in
the shower sometimes I'll think of just
like really like just bad moments and
you just you're just thinking about bad
moments in the shower sometimes lame
[__] yeah just the lamest [__] you could
have done that like in the grand scheme
of things as an adult it shouldn't
matter but it just still always gets you
it's not every shower relaxing it's not
every shower okay but you just tend to
have these thoughts I remember I was in
seventh I think I was in seventh grade
there's a dude named Bob Cristo I
remember him he was like this like a
little Hood little Mexican dude but um
he just was like a tough guy and
everybody would just [__] all over him
so it just made it easy for me and like
at that time I was still trying to
figure out how to like fit in with
everybody cuz I was new to school so I
figured if I [__] pick fights with
this dude cuz he would talk [__] to me
if I pick fights with him people would
like me more or something I don't know
who [__] knows so we started fighting
in the [__] locker room for like uh
we're like we're like challenging each
other like postering like I'mma [__] you
up I'll [__] you up [__] that kind of
[__] yeah so we started scrapping a
little bit and uh at this time I was
super into professional
wrestling incredibly into it and um
before I was going to step up to him in
my head I was like yeah I'm going to hit
him with this I [__] stunn yeah bro
like just think about my moov sets I'm
throw them against the ropes yeah think
about my my finishing sequence until I
hit my finisher you know what I mean
such fake [__] so just like total crazy
[__] I remember okay bro your boy
started I was in the corner your boy
started tuning up the band you know what
that means tuning up the band there's a
guy named Shawn Michaels okay he used to
have this this finishing move called
sweet sh music where he sidekick you in
the face oh so you're doing this yeah
okay that's T okay that terrible awful
so B so bad the worst part though is
this is the worst part this is the worst
part this is real life he goes hey and I
was like what he's like you watch
wrestling and I was like yeah he's like
I watch wrestling too I go
we became friends after that we became
friends you still try to make him an
enemy you're like I watch you're like I
watch WWF but he watched WCW you watch
WCW yeah yeah which one do you like
Smackdown or Nitro dude which one is it
it better be Nitro was everyone around
you like boo what the you know what the
funny thing was there was like nobody it
was just me and him so like if I beat
his [__] ass no nobody nobody the
bottom card bottom card everyone's like
waiting to show up nobody asked for this
fight nobody was championing me like oh
my God nck you're going to beat as [__]
that's the undercard I'm going to go
later I'm going to go like you may not
have found out you guys had that call
interest if it wasn't for this stupid
situation even our even our friendship
didn't go to you know the SC shower so
like there's no net positive like this
is something I could friendship is
better than an alteration that's true
that's true but we were already kind of
fighting and I was already being a
[__] so maybe I did learn to not be
a piece of [__] but at the same time
when I think about it I'm like I gained
nothing from that except embarrassment
and secondhand embarrassment from
everybody watching that is pretty funny
though bro it was real bad very bad
barwan if you could erase one thing or
event from your memory what would you
choose I know exactly the thing let's go
Joe knows this story I don't know if you
guys have heard of this one um so when I
was
in fourth grade or fifth grade yeah
around fourth or fifth grade
I was in Boy
Scouts
and so I was in Boy Scouts and I
remember we were at at um at one of our
meetings it was one of those like um all
the parents come cuz it's like a
promotional meeting type of thing where
people are going to get promoted or
they're going to get their new like
patrol leader or like new new jobs or
whatever oh I think I know the story you
toally here so all the parents they get
to sit in chairs cuz you like the the
way like a lot of these meetings work
you would go and you'd get the foldable
chairs right and all the kids they set
up like rows of four or whatever or five
or six cuz sometimes the meetings are
either at like a multi-purpose room of
elementary school or a church or
whatever and then the kids just kind of
sit around on the floor so the parents
right here they're doing the [__]
senior patrol leader leading with the
[__] Pledge of Allegiance and all
that [__] and um I'm sitting in the back
right here with all the all my other
friends very quiet you know cuz it's
like a ceremony so one person speaks at
a time like a master of ceremony and
like okay now we're going to do this now
we're going to [__] lead us into
prayer or whatever all that kind of [__]
[__] then my mom's sitting in front of
me she goes like this she [__] tilts
one ass cheek up and
go
and everyone starts [__] laughing
because they know who the [__] did it
and I go and I remember the adults and
everyone and my mom and my mom never
comes to my events so I'm like why the
[__] did she has to do I'm like this is
the reason why I never [__] ask you
to come cuz you always embarrass me I
remember my ears turning [__] bright
was she completely fine with that she's
completely fine she's like that was
funny she didn't even address it it was
just B and just go R like so when
everyone's laughing what's she doing
she's just like she's not embarrassed I
think she's oblivious she really doesn't
connect that they're laughing she oh
they told a joke no it's kind of like
like let's say a recently immigrated
Chinese person like if the Uber driver
is yelling at her they're like okay okay
okay I don't know know give me the
[__] address okay okay okay yeah so
she's just like B and everyone's
laughing she's probably just
like oh [__] and then I remember
everyone started clowning on me laughing
at me and I'm just like son of a [__]
this is why I never [__] invite you
to places and then afterwards I think
driving home I was
like like Mom like why did you do that
and she goes what do you mean I was like
you farted and like everyone started
laughing at me and you're embarrassing
me in front of all my friends and she
goes what do you mean like I I didn't uh
I didn't fart or like she goes I didn't
fart on purpose like yes you did you
lifted up an ass cheek D let it out I
didn't she was like no I'm just I was
just stretching I was just moving my
posture she's that oblivious and I was
like [__] I made a squeak I've I've
seen you do that that [__] at home where
you [__] lift that sh apart that's
your signature move and the reason why I
want to erase that one is
because seeing how that like what
happened there I'm like it did didn't
make me who I am
today and it literally added zero value
it was just a moment of intense
embarrassment for no reason it didn't
make me that's an amazing [__] story
though I mean the the the meaning the
purpose of it was now you can share
something so amazing with your friends
on JK of all the trauma things he's like
I climbed into a clock to save my own
life I still think that's entertaining
but those things like I gained value
like even with what happened with my
pops like it transformed the way I
thought about things there's so much
like like I like I became a different
person right like very transformative
and and she fart and she gaslit you yeah
the person that I was before and after
the fart is the same except I was
intensely embarrassed the funny thing is
she didn't even know that people were
laughing she just let it go and then
after she's all defense about it like I
the chair was squeaking she already the
weird person like my mom like like at
the meeting she was wearing [__] like
ballet shoes or something and I'm like
Mom can you just wear some normal [__]
like why are you wearing this and she's
like oh look that's flat shoes flat
shoes good for your feet I'm like ain't
nobody wearing flat shoes like she wore
like these ballet slippers that she used
to wear when she was like in like uh
high school or Junior High I'm like just
so when she walks into a room it
attracts attention already so it's
already you know like the whole recipe
is just like can you just be [__]
normal and then she farts on top of it
yeah like every other parent here is
shoes everyone here is normal why you
got to [__] wear ballet shoes and be
the lady that farts in the front would
it have made would it have made anything
easier if she's all hey guys check this
out that would have been
cool I'm Bart's mom I think that would
have made her really cool cuz at least
that's kind of funny yeah cuz this
should be oh she's the funny lady right
right but she's not she's just if she
was like excuse me I have a question and
they'll be like yes and she
went dude everyone would have been like
yeah par mom is cool see it's all
execution it's all exec yeah yeah you
got to own it once you fart you got to
own it bro she went dude that's crazy
she didn't even realize she farted she's
making excuses like that was the chair
that's pretty crazy though to have to
hear that as a kid to be like I didn't I
know I didn't she been weird man she
been weird that's so funny yeah so for
me I guess it wouldn't be my mom like
just farting somewhere I guess like
that's traumatic
though I guess it's really hard for a
kid if your mom just farts somewhere for
me it'd be like yeah my dad not cheating
on my
mom uh no for me for me it's very simple
I'll never forget this it's so bad it's
like I'm so I'm my my first girlfriend
and I I was talking to you guys earlier
about
soaking we did that kind of [__] and it
was like such [__] [__] and then
one time it was [__] yes I got greedy
and you started thrusting it went
further o yeah exactly pumped it a
little bit pump I was pumping a little
bit right but then in an act of
cowardice afterwards and this is like I
didn't talk about it for another like 9
days with her and like you know I was
like in the middle of dumping here and
with that and I was like by the way
before I was going to dump her though I
was like we didn't even really we didn't
even really do it oh I was like we it
was like nah we didn't do it that's not
technically doing it like to save so
you're both like we're virgins save my
Catholic guilt I was like outwardly
projecting my virginity even though like
come on dude it's over yeah it's gone
your V card's ripped up it's over and
then you did she agree she was like
devastated oh that's a hard yeah je like
wait you wanted to break up because of
the guilt no I was like pretty moved on
cuz there was like a lot of emotional
stuff he wanted to break cuz he already
got
it go that's how it is that's how boy
boys will be boys to delete that moment
that's pretty [__] no but I just
didn't have the balls to handle that
moment right cuz it just happened and
stuff and like say it doesn't count you
don't forget it and like I was like 15
years old it's so stupid like this was a
long long time ago but you don't forget
how embarrassing it is that you pulled
some move like that and you thought that
was tight and you're like oh yeah I got
away with that one you know like you
walk out of that conversation like I'm
still a virgin we're good check the
highman
boys and like yeah meanwhile like still
straight edge yeah exactly and meanwhile
like you know yeah her shit's like she
got off a jet ski that [__]
got you know what I mean like it's
different it's different yeah no
recovery it's different for the girl
Shep different for the girl a lot
different that's rough oh you were like
I didn't feel a thing no it's so
embarrassing every time I think about
that I shatter like you don't talk about
shower Thoughts with yourself well it's
also so uncharacteristic of how you
think now you know what I mean like you
would [__] that guy dude yeah I would
[__] dunk all that guy but that's why
I hate that guy cuz I was that guy at
one point same same reason why like
thinking of myself in a violent way is
so [__] weird maybe you have to do
that in order to cringe at that yeah oh
yeah no you have to have inner knowledge
of it for sure yeah yeah yeah but yeah
and I'm sure farting was bad
too they were probably calling it fart
the rest of the oh fart Quan really good
really
good once you Del that memory dude
amazing of all the memories he shared
with us he's like M I'm ripping one in
church dude but did that ever happen in
other places movie farting other places
yeah if she was so used to that did she
ever like pretty hard she repeat I think
I'm used to her so if it happens in
other places it doesn't bug me but when
like she's entering into my world like
if we go to 99 Ranch I'm in her world
right and she's like shopping
cart I'm like I don't care I'm [__]
here with you you're doing your thing
but when you come to my thing and then
you [__] bring those ways bring those
ways oh God [__] d if you could erase
one thing or event from your memory what
would you choose Anthony Lee and
remember we only have like a couple
minutes so like just wrap it up short
real short just keep it quick yeah we
there's a lot we know 20 seconds if
possible you did a lot of shows so I
like genuinely hate this question
because when I think of something that
like actually bothers me but it's okay
um so it was late 2009 right and uhit I
was I was living in an apartment on
campus uh at UCI and my current roommate
at the time was actually Boy Scout
related somebody who was like a really
really close friend of mine came up
through Boy Scouts and stuff like that
now here the problem was is that coming
up in the Boy Scouts my sister was also
in the same like Scout Troop and stuff
like that so we were all friends and
then finally like that friend threshold
like crossed and then my roommate and my
sister started dating
oh yeah and I again they're F in more
ways than one obviously and I remember
coming back when one time from class and
I remember like Mike and them they be
like no no Anthony don't go upstairs and
I was like what dude you know just
like and you heard your sister moan no
dude thank you for telling the rest of
did she more than moan yeah but
basically yeah I didn't walk in or
anything like that but it was just one
of those why what the [__]
and and obviously you get the hint and
then it's like a [__] you know you're
just like cool about it because you're
you know your college
kid but once the volume started to hit
you oh shut
up and and maybe dude maybe your
roommate was a little bit kinky too yeah
so then your sister stop stop no no I'm
just I'm just pitching I'm pitching I
don't know maybe he's so maybe she's
like she's like oh my God I'm anthon
Le's [__] sister I'm anth Le
Sister Sister maybe I don't know I don't
know I'm pitching I don't know we don't
know we were there did you want to go
outside immediately or
you outside I went outside oh god dude
this is I'm surprised you didn't grab a
box of Kleenex and run by the door and
start jacking
off he puts a bug to the
door oh my
[Laughter]
God what was the conversation like when
they came downstairs hard dude I was
just not around I think I went to like
the local [__] Bubba shop or some sh
choer team [__] and I was just like I'm
out she like Anthony I'm a little dick
drunk can you come pick me
up
[__] you're a bad guy dude you're a bad
guy